hey guys i'm ryan right add Cassandra
Michaels so today we're gonna check out
this video called racist field trip it's
supposedly absolutely hilarious I'm not
racist but I like a good racist joke
every once in a while
specifically blacker oh no I'm not
bugging around people Christmas field
trip I have ever feel on my [ __ ] life
they took us to a [ __ ] cotton
processing place and it was a big ass
cotton field out in the middle of
[ __ ] Rhema Alabama in the south of
luck every county we went there and me
and 28 other little diglettz in Miss
Hawkins third-grade classroom it took I
asses out there in the middle of the
[ __ ] August heat and said hey y'all
think Avis bags and [ __ ] right little
cute little black bag with a chip with a
cotton pump person with a smile on his
face and they're like hey y'all go up
y'all go out there have fun pick as much
cotton as you want and so my stupid
hands with no I wish my mother signed on
for and didn't think about it and I went
to the [ __ ] field trip I didn't feel
good every good whole time we were
singing songs [ __ ] baby god I'm in the
middle of [ __ ] heat and then yo I'm
thinking because it's a field trip they
told us you can pick as much as you want
hey you get to keep the [ __ ] guy you
can keep so I was like yeah oh we keep
it and we're gonna get back on the bus
to my kids
turn your bags in let me take my asses
inside and took all the damn cotton that
we had and they had told us to get back
on the [ __ ] bus so me being a little
rebel
I took a handful of cotton stuffed it in
my pocket and went home then my mom okay
who is she was doing laundry the next
night she was like what the [ __ ] is this
cotton in your bed
I was like here what the hell did you
get unprocessed we're all cotton from
well yesterday on the future it took us
to a cotton processing plant we got the
pig Cotton's all game to the school wave
I swear to God that just [ __ ] wait down
she lockers woman in a room like how
dare you jive ass [ __ ] take my
head and all these are the action or
Negroes to a [ __ ] cotton field in the
middle of the song you soulless [ __ ]
she [ __ ] checked me out of school I
didn't go to school for three days by
then she said I don't want to have to
look at that [ __ ] she was everybody yes
how's the most racist [ __ ] I've ever
gone through in my life I didn't even
understand what was wrong until the next
year how did he gonna say that I just
thought we were just gonna go have some
fun in the feed - you that was [ __ ]
[ __ ] - if I ever seen [ __ ] this [ __ ]
about the region whoo oh my god wow it's
pretty crazy story that's really [ __ ]
up is really [ __ ] up
Wow I mean it makes me think of like cuz
my dad I mean I've never gone into this
on the channel but my dad was someone
who had some racism issues for sure it
is weird how like you know if you teach
kids racism early on it was a strange
now as I get a little bit too personal
here like I'm half Filipino and my dad
was surprisingly racist against
Filipinos too and so he constantly put
down Filipinos and stuff and even though
it's just my dad's opinion it would
affect the way I felt you know in
affecting my mindset towards Filipinos
and towards myself you know he's talking
about this happened and when he was
young
yeah of course especially when you're
young though like to have somebody older
yeah you know come down you like that
like it's just not cool and then to
throw like you know it is pretty [ __ ]
up to take like a young black kid and be
this tear pick some cotton dude what
school do you go to in like who
authorized this trip who does that you
know dealing with that it's you know I
could see how it could [ __ ] with
like if his mother wasn't like this is
[ __ ] up
his mom was awesome by the way yeah it
could have been something that like if
he found out about it later on and my
affected him yeah yeah like if he found
out later on like oh this is what they
did to slaves like it might have like
[ __ ] with his mind a little bit more
yeah so it is important to have like
that parental figure really instill in
you that racism is like [ __ ] up yeah
so I totally agree because I think
racism is pointless I really do yeah how
have you met enough people of the same
race to go
I hate millions of people like you yeah
whatever it yes ridiculous but you don't
like Armenian people right right that's
what I really like Armenian people if I
recall you said all Armenian people can
go to hell I don't never said that do
not get me in trouble
Armenia I love you sure you said that's
what you want on your tombstone yeah no
no I'm just kidding guys I love Armenian
she's early Nance she prefers Armenians
he Cassandra you want to go do my BMW
we got hookah yeah
Oh God okay God here we go understanding
less is a night felt you some racist
jokes really get you know if I make a
racist joke on [ __ ] early the idiot of
the joke yeah of course of course you
know I'm not saying like here's my point
like I'm clearly like someone who's a
dumbass for saying that yeah so I don't
want people to think like I'm a legit
racist cuz I I'm very much against it I
understand that was very heartfelt yeah
yeah except all Chinese people do know
kung-fu and are good at math I can't
resist I'm sorry good the math though
the math and math at is the one thing we
can all agree like it's just in there
like wow then black people tend to be
cut you know once I get fat which is a
fact for everybody which doesn't really
matter anyway guys thanks for tuning in
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out the Sandra's channel there's a
lot of original songs and cover
seriously some great stuff you got to
check it out and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
we're trying to get product placement
from place mats
police fats are great placement
sometimes you're eating food drops on
the placemat you're okay
solid like why would you want that to
get on the table sometimes you're about
to come on a girl's face or maybe if
you're gay a guy's face and you know if
it you don't want you on the floor
that's why you put a placemat there
Aaron Jennings hey Ryan
Jerry and the whole gang I have been
watching the channel for over a year
that's crazy
I've only been interacting lately
because I wasn't really into that on any
YouTube videos I've just watched the
videos without commenting and I am very
sorry for that but seeing that you guys
put a lot of effort into your videos it
is hard to sit here and watch a video so
if you guys gave me a shout out that
would be amazing
I think anyways felt this message
anything works on my pages or I'm
screwed stay awesome guys and I forgot
greetings from Ireland Ireland
he's from Ireland Oh Aaron Jennings
speaking of racism or Irish people like
potatoes and Lucky Charms we all right
rich people like to drink a lot too I'm
Irish and I like potatoes Lucky Charms
yeah and I like to drink and I'm fine
with that
that means cassandra has an abusive
husband who likes to beat her when he
gets drunk right now
oh no and that husband is Erin Jennings
you keep doing what you gotta do Erin
sometimes you got to put this woman in
her place out of control clearly
obviously no yeah you are out of control
I know you are constantly just ready to
jump on any Irish dick you see your
parents well I watch these videos I hope
not I hope they do they don't have a few
things lore about Irish me do